have you got any comments asking like oh
how's your Japanese coming along oh why
are you not why are you not fluent yet
oh all the time you've lived in Japan
for a year and you're not fluent in
Japanese
I'm working on it I'm working on it it's
okay it's okay except for him except for
him yeah
I'm working on it but yeah it's been a
lot of fun I mean like you know there
aren't like enough annoying comments for
it to truly be an issue yeah it's
something I've noticed yeah where it's
like
it's people who
like expect you to just constantly like
be loving everything yeah or or people
who want you to be having a miserable
time for some reason what I found
fascinating I feel and this isn't every
single comment that's like the the Japan
hating comments but I've noticed a lot
of comments that are like very against
Japan and want you to also have a bad
time uh probably people who once lived
in Japan or spent a while in Japan and
maybe didn't have the best time and
they're like salty yeah and they're
salty that yeah they're seeing you have
a good time it's either like people it's
not every comment obviously oh yeah of
course but like I've noticed that
there's people who will just be salty at
the fact that I live here yeah I think I
think it's also because it's it's um
maybe some commenters or some viewers
they see how how we got here and you
know it's very rare circumstance and I
think it's very lucky yeah I think I
think that also it can annoy people
because they're like that's [__] up
that they get to go and you maybe do
this yeah why can't that be me yeah yeah
yeah I'm not saying that's all of it but
I you know I think there's a lot of
aspects to it yeah and you know we're
very lucky and we get to no no yeah yeah
we get the best of both worlds
underground we don't have to work
in the Japanese company yeah we can we
can still live in Japan and have all the
benefits of that sure sure yeah I feel
like there has been a recent new wave of
how you call it like Japan dick riders
as well oh my gosh just because just
because I've seen like a massive new
trend when YouTube shows and tick tocks
that are just like weak like I I feel
like the you know J vlogging scene we
had like they had like exposed most of
the things you can find in Japan right
now on like the normal day-to-day basis
you know you can't really have in a j
Vlog oh look at this vending machine
anymore because we all know about the
Japanese vending machines but it feels
like to tick tock they're they're just
discovering this right yeah where you
find you find shorts and you find tick
tocks where it's just like look at this
10 reasons why pan is living in the
future
number one you can use Asuka in a
vending machine I'm like other countries
have that too some of them like I'm like
like lie yeah what is it I saw one that
was like people are lining up four hours
at Starbucks for this new drink and I'm
like I can go down the street and get
that drink in like two minutes no one's
lining up four hours way more Starbucks
is than are needed in Japan
I don't I don't I hate that people are
just taking like the most mundane things
and trying to be like
isn't this crazy because in Japan yeah
because like you're spawning more like
Japan dick riders yeah exactly and it's
just those crazy Japanese
what's as long as you waited in line for
or anything in Japan oh Cafe two hours
two hours
you are the person waiting in line Emily
not a bank
the hospital
[Music]
wait okay another one I'm sorry I feel
like I'm complaining too much welcome to
trash day welcome to trash days this is
this is uh okay okay you know what other
comment that I saw a lot of at the
beginning that I thought was so like
annoying and like patronizing when I
made the video of like I moved to Japan
you get all the comments that are like
you know it's not like the animes right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like oh no no
there's no there's no time no [__]
like
um
I'm gonna like moved you think I'm gonna
turn my life around overseas move to
this country and you think me at my big
girl age thinks that I'm about to walk
into like my high school rom-com Shojo
dream are you kidding me yeah I mean
it's because it's because you know
they're normally dumb kids saying that
[__] and yeah they're probably 15
themselves or it's people who you know
because they only they only see the your
videos boom you're in Japan so for them
it's like oh what the [__] yeah yeah
like you mulling over the decision me
telling you 500 times on on call you
should come over here they don't see
that they don't see the Visa person I
know but I'm like come on no I know I
know like hot sake hot take
I think honestly if you've gone through
that like period in your life where you
have been like a massive let's say Japan
dick rider super weebie that's fine man
I think it actually helps you no it does
you know a lot of information okay okay
wait what helps you
um just kind of have like not being
afraid to kind of like do a lot of
people in the west if you're like overly
weebie or something like that it's kind
of cringe right yeah I thought learning
Japan was cringe yeah Japanese sorry
yeah I thought London Japanese was so
like oh you're learning anime that's
yeah [__] I should have learned it and
and I will I will say like now that we
like live in Japan
um we you know communicate with Japanese
people way more often I'm so [__]
jealous of Sydney because she has no
shame at all in like being as like you
know she's been through her weebie phase
yeah that's just Sydney that's just
Sydney but like every time we go like
traveling or anything like that we go
like just different places she has like
no shame at all and like trying to like
what you you know do things that in our
minds was like perceived as weebie but
in here in Japan it's like people
[__] love it here because you know
you there's someone that's kind of like
trying to
learn about that culture oh if there's
one thing Japanese people love it's
someone who's not Japanese trying to be
Japanese yeah exactly exactly like it's
like oh they're embracing our culture
like they're trying to you know like
assimilate and like that makes our life
easier yeah old people or something
but you know it's like seeing someone
like trying really hard to like you know
uh talk to someone in Japanese they're
like wow
trying to communicate with us that's so
nice yeah like Sydney gets treated so
well when we go travel because she has
had this like eccentric weeb phase and
she's not afraid to do
um and like you know for a long time I
thought it was cringe and here in Japan
I'm like [__] man that should have been
me I should have done that I could have
got a head start damn it I noticed that
um because obviously when I started
learning Japanese more and speaking it
that um when I kind of copied the
mannerisms of uh like Japanese people
when they speak like a bit more quiet a
bit more reserved
um that there are I don't know it was
like a lot harder to communicate and
sometimes there would like be walls
there but the moment I started kind of
speaking Japanese but also being way
more confident and more like kind of
just extroverted with it they're they're
super more chill about yeah they get way
more open to it yeah I think that's what
it is like yeah I think when they see
you speaking Japanese but still having
that kind of fun extroverted uh
personality with it I think it helps so
much yeah people are sure because they
probably see that you're comfortable
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
basically I keep telling me about hentai
basically what I realized after
returning after actually moving to Japan
we have to return to weeb that's we must
return to weave that was the hype with
it man yeah crazy if if you think you're
acting like [__] anime probably
Japanese people will actually be more
receptive
maybe not online well maybe not all the
way no maybe not
just like more eccentric more confident
don't end your sentences with like this
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah okay no no not
that far not that far even Japanese
people would be like okay
that's going too far away go back go
back I started I started using uh more
uh friendly uh what's the word when you
end the sentence uh what's the casual
you know like yeah yeah when you coming
Gucci that's how you say like yeah like
the not casual one right not okay yeah
yeah I started doing speaking more
casual like not saying like the that's
correct
I know those people are way more
receptive yeah and I I think it's purely
because I'm I'm white
yeah they're like more chill about it
than if I don't speak more natural yeah
because there's something about it
because you know when you when you when
you speak in like a keger like you know
this or whatever they probably think oh
you're maybe not as well versed in
Japanese or like not as comfortable
right because you sound like you learned
from a textbook which you probably did
but like if you speak in a casual way
they don't teach that [__] to you in the
textbooks yeah so to them it's like oh
you actually know how to speak like real
Japanese people and not from a textbook
right so that's probably what it is yeah
I started testing I've been testing some
things I've seen how it goes limit
testing yeah I wanted to see which
things worked
um one thing that didn't work or at
least some sometimes got me like weird
looks is that
you're gonna I would uh
whenever I got out the taxi I'd leave
I'd just say oh my God
that's like see you later I'll see you
again like a friend because I wanna I I
just kind of I wanted to see how it goes
that's like that's like being like peace
some of them some of them would laugh
and some of them would be like what yeah
what do you mean we've seen each other
yeah it's funny yeah
just trying fun things yeah
yeah I keep doing more stuff yeah for
sure
yeah thank you very much